the inhuman behavior of Putin's War
Machine continues I think that the
resolve of the world to do more is
growing
and I am more than ever convinced that
Putin will fail
he will fail
he will fail in his catastrophic Venture
in Ukraine because he fatally
underestimated the heroism and the
resolve of the ukrainians to fight
he underestimated Western Unity
and among other things by the way he
underestimated the passionate commitment
of the people of this country to help
and since that great aberdonian Michael
Gove announced the scheme on Monday
we've seen 147 000 people and families
across the UK opened their homes to the
evacuees by the way many of them many of
the offers here in Scotland
aberdeenshire I'm told has the highest
number so far
[Applause]
who are doing it only a few weeks ago I
I was up here and I met some highly
skilled ship builders in Recife who were
fitting out two minesweepers uh to go to
help the Ukrainian Navy and of course uh
we will get them into the Black Sea as
soon as it is practicable uh to do so
but there is more that we can do now and
there's one crucial way
that we can all begin to help the world
to stand up to Putin and that is to wean
ourselves off dependence on his oil and
gas
and in that great National effort
a great National effort and a great
International effort Scotland will be in
the lead and I mean doubling down
doubling down on the UK's production of
offshore wind energy much of it driven
by the great aeolian gusts of wind that
I've seen myself of the of the Scottish
Coast
wind double down on that fourth march to
more more wind I mean investing in Tidal
we've put it we put 39 million into some
revolutionary uh projects some of them
here in in Scotland I mean more solar
power more nuclear power you've got to
make some big bets on UK nuclear power
and by the way I mean a lot more
hydrogen which is I understand it is
already already powering the buses here
in Aberdeen
is that right yes it's an extraordinary
it's fantastic
I also mean I also mean making sensible
use
of this country's own natural
hydrocarbon resources and are we not
completely shutting down domestic
production
only to buy oil and gas at a vast markup
from Vladimir Putin's Russia and yet
that unbelievably is the stated policy
of the Scottish national party and the
labor party
of course it was in Glasgow that the
world came together for that Epoch
making wonderful cop 26 Summit and we
all pledged to move Beyond coal and
hydrocarbon fueled vehicles and to plant
billions of trees and of course look at
what we've already done look at how fast
we've decarbonized our our economy and
our industry of course we can continue
the transition to a low carbon future we
can get to Net Zero in fact we can
continue to lead the world in cutting
carbon emissions as we have done but it
is also vital to recognize that in this
transition there will be a continuing
and vital role important role for oil
and gas
not least in producing hydrogen and
that's why it makes sense for the
government our government to continue to
help that crucial industry in the
northeast of Scotland with a North Sea
transition deal Worth 16 billion pounds
and I repeat what is the policy of of
Labor in the SMP turn off the Taps now
cap the wells at what a disaster that
would be it would mean prices up even
further it will mean jobs lost just when
householders are feeling the uh the
pinch of the high uh of the high gas and
and oil prices and of course it would
mean exposing the UK
to continued blackmail from Vladimir
Putin
together our country the UK is leading
the world in standing up to the
hydrocarbon drug pushing bully of the
Kremlin
and together we're going to wean
ourselves off that addiction to Russian
hydrocarbons and together we are a Force
for good in the world